in this capsule we will see how we
can approach the problem the
object recognition then we saw
previously only from an image on
could extract features
histogram histogram app
gradient which corresponds to calculate
gradian exchange partition the image
in multiple segments extract there in
each of the segments a histogram of
gaza that is there is finally
convert all this story g from
gardians there in water vector we
could give as input a proud glaze
linear as a tax collector a
logistic regression oumaima casper no
linear as a case on a body more
near neighbor or a neural network
so that's a way to solve by
example the problem of recognition
of objects so this problem here corresponds
to take an image and to identify if
a certain type of object is beautiful and
well in the picture
or not for example no need to
object recognition this is the
pedestrian recognition have created a
image and one would like to identified in
the image if they find a
pedestrian or not so what can we do
that's the problem
object recognition
pedestrians or any object of
generally as a problem of
standard classification in apprenticeship
automatic
so what would we do if we
would build a training set
where people very excited corresponded to
the rogge representation is a
gradient histogram for an image
given is the target yt that would be a
indication of the presence so there
connect one or the absence ci is equal
zero for a given object we want
recognizes laurent collecting a set
workout like that we could
give this training set the a1
to cure given learning they
learn to make the link between and to
make a prediction from an entry
the presence or not of a given object
in the image represented by the entrance
an example here of works that have
always attack this problem in this
that if the problem of detecting
two pedestrians so people actually
in images we have the image we saw
previously and as well as
characteristics corresponding to
gradient histograms and what has been
done here is that several examples
like that so that would be an example
yt feast on 1 since well and truly a
pedestrian a person in the picture
so we gave pictures like that
as well as other images where there would be
be pedestrian let's not be so we would
would have to collect images of both
types give back meaning to lead a
classified as minor is shown
here is what the classifier has learned
in fact it shows that they are the
weights that have a positive value so
we remember that in a classic and
linear we have a weight wy for each
entries explains in my sector
to enter wy multiply xxi in my
prediction
in fact if wy is positive it means
that the presence so a high value
of eksi and a helmet educator
also for this problem if of class 1
therefore the presence of a pedestrian
and then if double life was negative with
a high value of eksi created a
education of the absence of a person
in the picture
and when we can do lustrous series in
made for the skin positive to what
gradient orientation that corresponds
in the picture
and that's what we have here illustrated
only orientations that have a
high positive weights have done there
the presence or importance of a
gradient basically corresponds to
how much weight and such a life is
what we observe is that we made
positive steps that fits more or
less to the shape of a person in at
center of an image that no
to actually be successful who
could match the head
here we have traits that could trace
the contours of a person's shoulders
and if it could be the feet of the
no one here legend and we rather
others a trait that are less
competitive with the shape of a
nobody during that if the workbook
have essentially learned to detect
the shape of a person in a picture and
to ignore what might
maybe was in rather in
the background of a person has
found in the center of an image for if
you want more details on this
classification system there I you
encourages to consult the book of
Nordic resources
now if we have a proud glaze that
able to tell if an object is
in an image but that the way we have
trained a class up by going the
images or object were six
find the pictures he was at
center of the image how is that
now we're doing a detection of a
object so could be found
anywhere in the picture
the general approach is actually
simply to apply our ranking
in question but to apply it to
several positions in the image and to
several possible scales let's start
by cosec imagine we have this
image there as well as we want to detect a
face so we classify faces
who were trained on pictures where
the face was in the center of the image
because if what we could do
actually extracted all the images
possibly with overlap so
at all possible positions in my
my overall image which is bigger
typically that the images that I have
given in input of my case so proud of
my image detector is what I
will do is that my class
h for each of these worries image there I
ask him to tell me is it
with what confidence if they believe that
there is a face there
in the picture and if that would give me a
new image if we want them
would contain each position
the confidence of the classifier so
question arises that black that fits
at a high confidence that a face then
low trust white
so that would give me an image that
could look like this here so we
would have a lot of blacks to the plates of
positions where is an image then the
black the confidence finally would diminish
offered music we would move away from
each of the pictures have pale faces and
finally to have a single position
unique
we can apply an operation of
English this is called our maximum
China roughly the way it's
works is to take each of
answers here and check in a
auto window is what the answer of the
center and the maximum response in the
window
if so I will keep the value at a
high confidence value otherwise I'm going
do a deletion finally of the
value towards zero trust so in
this case because it's not the value
higher to see all high
rather find here ben the answer so
the position associated with that window there
now a value of zero for
trust on the other hand at the center where
confidence is the highest she is
actually trust more she lives
in a window around and there we go
keep a positive value of the
confidence of the answer so we succeed
finally to remove this uncertainty
on the exact position of the face and
get more specific points where
could find the face
now good for a given image in
does he could have pictures close
to decide photos for example near
the camera in the distance
how are we able to
detect those faces that if they could
to be in the background is recovering
smaller than the faces closer to
the camera so bigger in the image this
that we want in practice these camps do
take the picture in question and then we go
generate multiple versions of this
image there but on scales
different and then of that for
each of the images we will calculate its
answers there with windows but who
always going at the same time so the
extreme windows in the windows
by whose images under a ladder
different sales correspond in fact
to a size plus a surface more
big in the given image so that's fine
to finally detect the
faces on different scales and for
improve detections can do
else
other things we can try to
correct by by elimination so even
if the two guardians histograms are
quite robust
sometimes we can make improvements
from this point of view I will not talk about it
here you can consult the literature
to know more we can also
and estimate the orientation of the object that
could be in the image so if
in the face what I could not do
a rotation of the image of the window
for example the window here before the
give as input to monk the sphere and there
extract features
so it's possible to
develop algorithms that make
is that they are trying to do this
rotation there and so that allows in addition
to have a little more than a variant on the
possible rotations of an object
would like to detect so to have
more information when once i
invite you to consult the law book
underlines rich as well as the different
references that are already there that that
gives you an idea the general of
how does multiple systems work
recognition of objects in vision by
computer